It's a human. I see. It's
humanoid meat. I'll
try to examine it. Wait a minute. I was surprised. It's
actually a human.
How did a human drop something from a slime?
Slime Drops
Everything in this world is dropped in dungeons.
[Music] The
slime drop on the first basement floor of the level is a bean sprout.
What is this? What on earth does this mean?
[Music] There's nothing
good about Level 1. The drop
is also very low.
QRS Wait a minute, S.  Is it low?
[Music]
When I found out that I was level 1, I
thought I was going to be forced to live another life of hell where no matter what I do, I won't be rewarded, but
if I have this strongest skill with a drop rate of all S, I
'll be able to do it this time.  Don't skimp on the
skill. It's
level 1, but it's the strongest unique skill.
Broadcast starts in July 2023